and when I thought about this theme I
really had only one person on my mind
who I wanted to bring and and and have
talked to us which is Professor Susan
Crawford
Susan is a dear friend she's someone who
has sort of emerged in the last 12 years
or so as one of the most important
thinkers about not just how we run the
Internet and she's had real experience
with that spending a lot of time on the
board of directors of ICANN but also
what we can do with the Internet so
she's someone who's been thinking not
just about the sort of the hard
architectural issues the questions of
how we maintain net neutrality although
in that case she literally is the person
who has written the book that is
probably the best introduction to
understanding why the u.s. is in such a
strange and such a poor position as far
as our access to the Internet a book
called captive audience which if you
hasn't read you really do need to get on
your bookshelf it's absolutely required
reading for anyone who thinks about the
political and civic significance of the
Internet she's someone who's incredibly
passionate about the open Internet and
celebrating it she's the founder of one
web day which has been a holiday to
celebrate the web as we know it this
open participatory civic space but she's
now moving in her work to thinking
really more broadly about what happens
when we do have this open Internet what
can we do with it and working with
Stephen Goldsmith she has a book coming
out this fall called responsive City and
she's really thinking about the ways in
which a city that is wired a city that
is filled with sensors a city that is
filled with people who can ask questions
and who can share all that information
really change what it means to be a
citizen I find her inspiring every time
I hear her talk I'm so thrilled that
she's able to be here and lead off this
conference for us please welcome to the
stage Susan Crawford
[Applause]
[Music]
well I'm delighted to be here and to see
so many friends this morning and the
idea of having a path to impact is
incredibly attractive to me that's I
think what we're all trying to find and
as I've been working so much on the
terrible internet access picture for
America I'm seeking optimism and I think
one way to get there is to look at all
the other communities that require open
fiber in their towns and they are
journalists people who care about the
civic life of cities and government we
all need this so in for the last year or
so working with Steve Goldsmith former
mayor of Indianapolis and former deputy
mayor of for operations of New York City
with Mike Bloomberg I have been working
on a book coming out on in September
called the responsive City and here's
the draft cover looking at all these
ones and zeros on the cover and
preparing for this talk made me think of
a conversation I had last month with an
anthropologist Norwegian anthropologist
who had spent years working in Malaysia
with very isolated tribes in the 70s and
she's very disturbed about a turn in her
field in the field of anthropology
towards what people are calling post
humanism the idea that the human is no
longer at the center of discourse for
anthropology that instead we need to be
thinking about the feelings of trees and
the feelings of every other element
putting humans is just a relative you
know point of data when it comes to
anthropology not the center and then she
leaned forward and she said it's all
tied to this idea of smart and here is a
gift for you how she thinks of smart it
is simplistic mechanistic a historical
reductive and tautological so all the
stories about smart cities and smart
ways of instrumenting city
to her seem fundamentally posthumanist
somehow mechanical and simplistic this
also rang true for me when I heard Dan
Hill speak
late last year in Amsterdam who talked
about what he calls the urban
intelligence industrial complex a group
of companies that are working towards a
vision of instrumenting cities gathering
data and then selling products that are
based on that data
I think the posthumanist critique is
right and something we really need to
focus on when we talk about technology I
think smart the criticism of smart is
way overblown and we wrote responsive
City the responsive city to celebrate
and capture what cities can do working
with these other communities the open
fiber community the open data community
the civic activism world and journalists
to make their cities better places for
human beings to live because when we
forget that humans are the reasons for
cities we operate at our peril we
couldn't actually measure what's
wonderful about a city the energy and
the diversity and the joy that you get
walking through a great park like
Central Park here in New York City or
Boston on this sparkling day to have a
physicist view of the city to believe
that everything could be measured in
somehow tinkered with is clearly
short-sighted and uninspiring but there
is something there's a lot that cities
can do using data to enrich the lives of
the people who live there cities are
capable of great things of great changes
using a little bit of technology plus
open fiber to make lives better and
luckily for those who are really worried
about the overblown vision of smart
where everything has a digital point and
we're all nudged in ways we're not aware
of to change our lives cities are also
incapable of controlling large swaths of
urban life so in working on the
responsive city
I met many civic leaders working inside
the hot walls of City Hall who see this
balance between human beings and the
instrumental use of infrastructure and
all the things that make possible human
lives and cities here's Brandon Berman
she's terrific she's the CIO of citta go
and she is working on ways of using data
to target just the inspections that city
workers do to make sure that they're
using leading indicators about the state
of the world historically to focus their
efforts it's a very rigorous very
thoughtful set of work at Chicago's
carrying out very slowly with a lot of
testing a lot of computer scientists
involved behind her is the grid for
Wendy grid they call it the sort of
mapping in a human readable form of data
so you can see the city that they're
also launching just this week sensors
that are very carefully not collecting
personalized information but aggregate
information about the environment of the
city air quality pollution right co2
no.2 sound levels of sound noise in
other words and temperature and
instrumenting the city in that way and
then having the data come directly into
the city's open data platform where it's
available for use by researchers and by
the city itself for changing its
policies if there's pollution here why
is it there can we tinker with that can
we move with that with fiber in place
and sensors picking up this
environmental data there is a lot of the
city can do so there's brenna balancing
these human and instrumental interests
this is Mike flowers of New York City
who based on his experience in Iraq was
able to understand the functioning of
New York City government it's tribal
it's incredibly complex and there are
Wars right he saw that inside the New
York City government and as a very self
empowered civil servant went around
persuading people to share data with him
so that he could help them make their
operations better and the responsive
city tells the story of Mike flowers and
how he did this he's an example of how
data and technology can actually empower
our civil servants to have more dignity
and autonomy in their jobs
which then helps citizens have more
dignity and autonomy in their daily
lives here's bill Oates when he walked
into City Hall in Boston in 2006 as its
very first cabinet level CIO he heard
typewriters 2006 right so bill takes
this on and make sure that there's
adequate infrastructure inside the city
of Boston's you know environment but
also works closely very closely in
cahoots with Nigel Jacob and Chris
Osgood focusing always on finding ways
to use technology and applications that
will help citizens very much citizen
Center governance inspired by the mayor
Mayor Menino who his leadership was
absolutely essential the 20 years that
he'd been here as mayor made a huge
difference to this team it's all about
people in the end it's not just people
inside City Hall it's also people
outside City Hall here's Dan O'Neill the
indefatigable leader of the smart
Chicago collaborative who has worked
he's done many things in Chicago but
he's worked with nonprofits in the city
to gather information about
deteriorating buildings and get that
data right into the city's open data
portal through 3-1-1 and then have a
city streamline its operations so it
focuses on what those nonprofits are
worried about and actually acts on them
that feedback loop of response between
citizen and people inside City Hall
wonderful woman Carolyn Shannon who has
moved to the largest favela in Rio and
with her husband Pedro de Cristo is
building what they call the digital
Agora
a space with very good connectivity for
people to work on civic issues together
and to organize and to make sure that
the city hears about their concerns but
a space nonetheless where people can be
physically activists together and here
is the terrific Kathy Pettitte of the
Urban Institute these are all heroes in
my mind I can't help smiling they're
terrific she is working with nonprofits
across the United States through the
Urban Institute to help them build the
capacity
to use data to have an impact on policy
so you see this terrific feedback loop
being driven by these individuals so
they're great they're balancing concerns
about sensitivity and privacy and
autonomy and dignity with the need for
the city to just do a better job because
the city in America and around the world
is at a very primitive stage of using
all of this information there are such
barriers to adopting technology inside
City Hall's
still and enormous blockades in the form
of procurement rules you know it's human
resources requirements that get in the
way of this kind of agile development
it'll be very slow for seeds to actually
act on a lot of this input so the fear
about smart the reductive mechanic a
historical tautological world is
overblown in part because we have a long
way to go before we can actually help
change city government into becoming a
richer place so let's balance all this
we don't want to value efficiency over
compassion in the use of technology we
also though don't want to devalue
efficiency there's a lot we could be
doing better
making the systems of the city run
better for all of our lives and here's
the theoretical nugget the one thing I
want you to take away from this talk
which is that you can use data visibly
to enhance and amplify the touchpoints
of government and journalism on citizens
when you see something when you see a
visualization of what the city's doing
what a journalist is doing to report on
the city all made possible by use of
data and fiber in a city democracy is
strengthened because weak and
authoritarian governments operate
because there's a very thin strand of
relationship between the two of them
right you give me money I provide you
services and that's it and where a
government is uncertain and
authoritarian it will act through
coercion and threat rather than through
its citizens so paradoxically this
visibility of government actually
strengthens the
of democracy to serve all of our
interests and that's why I'm moving into
this new area because I think that
without this kind of visibility we won't
have the enhanced trust in government
that we'll need in order to accomplish
great things for citizens because none
of us acting on our own can provide a
post office or build a road to provide
fire service or you know policemen or
schools all of these are public goods
and we need to make sure that we have
the trust visible trust available for
those actions to be taken there are
wonderful tensions in this field that
are not going to go away we have decades
to work through this I hope it happens
more quickly but look at all this we
have all the centralizing push of urban
data networks data policies but they
make possible very fine-grained
neighborhood work both levels at once
this is very much an both and discourse
same point about leadership without many
no in place the neighborhood based
efforts using technology are more
difficult you need a strong leader in
order to keep the decentralized action
going deep personalization is possible
through these networks we can maybe have
our own vision of what the city is but
at the same time we need broad civic
concern in order to address the grand
challenges ahead of all cities around
the world sustainability and resiliency
also urban life thrives on inefficiency
New York is very inefficient Stockholm's
jealous because things run too neatly
there they wish they had the grit of New
York but if you have greater Civic
efficiency the city it becomes more
livable a better place to live so will
constantly be balancing these tensions
there is no one right answer there's a
tremendous amount of work to do
particularly on the policy side we need
to connect local organizing all the
civic energy of a place like a
transparent Chennai measuring and
mapping affordances in slums and then
trying to get the government to act on
that data right now that feedback loop
is feedback loop is less available than
it should be we need to figure out how
if the math tells us that treating
different areas will be fine the
outcomes will be good how does that fit
with our notion of
and ethics lots of differential
treatment questions coming up and
privacy and security and privacy and
security level endless conversations
about this and we need people to dig
into the policy in these areas and the
risk of meaningless engagement is huge
that you ask citizens to engage and then
you don't respond and then it's worse
than if you've never asked them in the
first place so lots of tough policy
questions that the responsive city
attempts to deal with it here's my
vision here's why I think all these
things fit together civic media fiber
municipal fiber people and local
government leaders because it's all
about the layers of infrastructure that
make the responsive city not the
authoritarian city but the responsive
city possible at the bottom you're
always going to need open fiber so that
everybody has the unlimited capacity
bandwidth they need to participate in
the city and in their own lives you need
open sensors like the city of Chicago
sensors that are reporting data that
people know about and it's made public
open data platforms also obviously
essential a new element for me that I'm
now beginning to understand is the
importance of shared screens not your
just your own handheld device but large
screens that allow people to look at the
same picture because the emotional heat
of policy conversations go down the heat
of conversations diminish when you're
looking at the same picture together so
screens everywhere are part of this new
vision of the responsive city and
publish algorithms if we're inspecting
data finding leading indicators trying
to predict how the city gets better we
should know what those algorithms are so
there you go that's the layered vision
that puts together what's possible for
journalists who are going to be
collecting all of this data and
reporting on it being part of our
knowledge of what the city is doing plus
the fiber people building networks which
are going to be essential plus the local
government leaders acting on this to
make lives better three suggestions when
you're worried about this smart city or
you're hopeful about the Smart City
always think they always ask yourself
the question compared to what a city can
do a better job knowing more about what
it knows people who want access to the
Internet can
better having fiber everywhere how is
this a delta how is this an improvement
we should always ask ourselves and I
think we should be optimistic there's
lots of room for thoughtfulness here the
policy questions have not yet been cited
a lot of them haven't even been asked
yet so we need to build the pipeline of
people who are trained both at MIT and
at policy schools or at mixtures of the
two so that they could engage in local
governments and be part or a part of the
citizen activist world and be able to
serve this world with activity and
passion the responsive City ultimately
is not posthumanist it is completely
human the human is at the center of our
discourse as it should be whenever we
talk about technology because after all
technology is culture thank you very
much Susan thank you so much and and
thanks for that provocation for people
who've been following Susan's work for
as long as I have it's really
interesting to see that something that
came directly out of your older work the
importance of having open fiber of
having broadband within communities now
turns out to be the backbone of this
very very ambitious vision but I'm gonna
reveal myself as one of the smart city
skeptics a few here in part because I'm
a city skeptic as you know I live way
way out in rural Western Mass but my
skepticism about the smart city is
really rooted in sort of Adam green
fields new book beyond the smart city or
against the smart city and he I think
would ask the question who gets to
respond so you gave us a bunch of heroes
they are really amazingly creative
people within city governments outside a
few outside how do people within
communities respond how do they use this
data how do they build on top of it how
does this become actually about the
people that are at the center of your
vision rather than just the people
within the government we are just at
such a primitive stage in the
development of this world we don't even
realize yet that there's no distinction
between the electronic
world and the on offline world there
they're the same it's just a flow of
information we should be living on many
layers at once but because our
infrastructure is so pathetic we think
of this as a special thing to be online
it's weird
so as this improves new kinds of
literacy emerge ways of dealing with
visualizations and understanding them
ways of interacting if all of this or
much of this information is open and
many different kinds of people can chew
through it and see pictures that relate
to it that makes possible engagement on
a scale we've never seen before and four
slices of your time slices of your
attention right now you'd have to go to
a city or town meeting a town meeting to
participate and it would take many
evenings and you might you know get
bored or wander away here if this vision
of the what we like your city to be is
actually a parent or something you can
just touch as you watch by you can give
it five minutes and and participate so I
think actually the amplification of
engagement is much greater
given this Ektron Eclair than it has
been in the past and actually we're
gonna see some student work a little bit
later today action path from Earhart
grave which works very much around this
idea of trying to get people to respond
in real time you're sort of in the early
stages of really exploring this new
vision scenario me Rosalie give me a
sense of what you're hoping will come
out of a situation like Chicago where
you've got these very capable sensors
coming up within an open data
architecture things go wonderfully well
over the next five years what do you
dream happens in the city of Chicago
with that with that sensor net five
years well I would we the city and its
citizens with any luck begin to
understand
pathways through the city differently
say start seeing the city differently as
a more more is revealed to people in the
city than had been in the past things
like where energy is hotspots to ignore
or go towards it's just the city of
Chicago is a wonderful place now it has
even more vibrancy with another layer of
information that people become so used
to it almost disappears it becomes just
another part part of the city visible to
them so that's my image just more of the
same more of what makes Chicago great
and energetic and diverse and
interesting plus a visual layer that's
available at anytime what what what
keeps me for feeling like I'm constantly
under surveillance in Chicago oh if we
feel like we're suddenly seeing these
patterns of energy right we're seeing
the past that I want to take and if this
is open data I assume that's also open
data to marketers I also assume that
that's open data to anybody who wants to
try to figure out how to target me as a
high energy guy deciding to engage with
a higher energy city how does that you
know avoid turning into the panopticon
which I know is not your vision of a
successful responsive city in this case
and this is where the role of policy is
so important and why the way that
Chicago is doing this carries so much
hope because they're very deliberately
not tracking individual people and not
looking for identifiers that would tie a
phone to a person they're looking to
just see levels of activity and each new
sensor will be looked at rigorously
through a public process to say do we
want this one do we want to add it
what's it going to be collecting and
because I realize this is a lot to ask
but because the information is public
people will see immediately if they're
troubled about either collection or
aggregation of the data so my rosy
vision is that that we're going to the
information is going to be collected the
city can be very deliberate
about D personalizing that information
to make sure that it's not actually
tracking a single person in Chicago to
its credit is taking that step very
intentionally right now so in just a
moment I'm gonna open this up to
questions from the audience and and in
fact I'm going to give my typical
academic institution what a question
looks like speech but before that I I
wanted to ask a particularly pointed and
may be targeted question which is this
Susan isn't this basically just the back
door to your your socialist utopian
dream of fiber backbones
holding together American cities you
know having not been able to vanquish
Comcast and Time Warner in front you
know facing mortal combat are you now
you know sort of going around the back
and essentially saying no no no no no I
don't want to destroy your duopoly all I
really want are nice open data and and
sensors is this not you know sort of the
back route to the fight that you've been
fighting for about ten years I love this
well actually I'm winning because around
the country thank you for that around
the country many mayors are looking at
opening up their own wholesale fiber
networks not actually entering into the
market themselves competing and
providing services but providing passive
infrastructure so that other companies
can build on top and provide competitive
services it's the Stockholm model it's
we're gonna see a lot of developments
along those lines coming up so having
won that battle and everybody in America
is on my side because we're sick of very
high prices and and the sense that
connectivity is a luxury that's the
essential problem in America that it
feels like a luxury now you need to
think about why why are we doing this
and I always think about humans that's
our point that's why we do anything
right and so humans want to be in each
other's presence they want connection
and having served briefly in government
I can see the possibilities of real
infrastructure provided by government
that it helps people's lives and so
putting all these things together I
think we're actually at a nice tipping
point
America for these issues to work
together there are enormous synergies
and journalists are also assisted so I
don't see it as a backdoor I see it as a
natural evolution of taking a
technocratic concern why is it so
expensive and making sure that the human
story is all always at the middle of it
so I'm gonna open up the conversation
here I know that there's a lot of
questions on the vision of the
responsive City Susan's work on a
variety of different subjects because we
are within an academic institution and
because there are a number of people who
have the word PhD after their name I
always feel like it's necessary to just
remind people that we're doing open
questions a question is an interrogative
statement it ends sometimes with a
raised voice and one way you can know if
you are asking a question is if there is
in fact something Susan could respond
after you were speaking if you find
yourself giving a speech and saying I
guess that's not a question you have
failed and keep in mind that I am the
person who's going to be running around
with the mic asking the questions
I am large I am grumpy and I take this
issue very seriously so if you have a
question that is actually a question
please put up your hands and I would
love to have you ask that question to
Susan if I have not now intimidated you
all into silence anybody please one yeah
great and if you would do me the favor
of just introducing yourself before you
ask the question here David Mathes and
sky truth I'm curious about so what
about places that don't perform well so
that somehow the sensor network shows
that this place has low energy or it's
bad obviously that becomes a place that
you target additional efforts but
doesn't that kind of confirm these
places are good but I always kind of
knew that part of the city was bad so
I'm not gonna have anything to do with
that well depends what you mean by bad
if if a section of the city is getting
inadequate resources from the city city
can then target it right that's one
thing to do with pollution is bad it can
on it if it's low-energy they're not is
enough foot traffic
maybe the citizens learn about that it's
amazing what people do when information
is visualized to them we only make
progress when we see something just
thinking about it never has the same
effect so I have this idea that people
in Amsterdam talked to me about this a
lot that making neighborhoods more
visible to themselves could in itself be
a tremendous assist to cities so we've
got a question over here from Alberto
ibarguen yeah
unlike Ethan I really do want to believe
you and I am an urban I've been a fan of
urban and I agree that Chicago is it
appears to be doing things right but it
could so easily not do it what do we do
to protect against say coming back to
the first Mayor Daley who might very
well have wanted to have the name and
and background information on all those
protesters in 1968 or anybody else how
can you protect against feeling like
we're encouraging big brother and this
is where the pipeline is so important
because training the next generation of
students who then see it as part of
their lives to go and serve in
government and understand that they can
have tremendous impact particularly in
the city federal level work is wonderful
I also recommend it but there's
something about working in a city that
allows you to see the impact of your
work that's extremely exciting getting
more people into local government who
understand this balance who are
sensitive to the risks and great
potential human potential of technology
is the only answer
making this a kind of a voting issue you
need to get leadership in office that
understands technology and doesn't see
it as alien and then getting people
inside to serve who are open to and
ready to act on all of these questions
we're getting there I believe my
students are part of that cadre I'm
pushing them out go do it
there are lots of people here who train
people who are in
being in that pipeline so that for me is
the only answer it's training good so
we're warming up at least three hands up
and we're going to work our way through
them Karolina Hosseini public knowledge
so Susan you said at the end that
technologists culture yeah right
and unfortunately here in the US the
culture is very permeable to
surveillance I'm sorry to touching the
same but I nearly moments right yeah a
couple of months ago I was in Boston and
the taxi driver driving around MIT said
and there it was where the the police
officer was killed and now I realized
yesterday that now the park is named
after him so the culture in us is
permeable to that so are you seeing the
limit very clear there or not yet and if
we think that a lot of laws are actually
secretive how much the the individuals
can actually impact on setting that
limits oh great well again these things
don't happen by magic there isn't some
exterior spaceship that lands on a city
and makes it tilt towards only acting
and surveillance this is all about
policy this is about who's there making
the decisions about what's gonna happen
and how the information flows are gonna
work information is going to be
collected we can't stop it it's a
tsunami right and it's too attractive to
too many people we can't get in the way
but what we can do is be really careful
about who gets access to it our forensic
abilities to track abuses inside
government and go after them say okay
you can't do that because that's
destroying the trust that people have in
government so looking backwards
forensically being careful about the
policies that shape the amalgamation the
data that's the answer because we have
this problem in America we sort of seem
to think that you know our terrible
internet access situation happened by
itself it didn't happen by itself it
happened because of policy decisions
along the line so we're permeable to
surveillance but we're also permeable to
democracy and the ability to make
decisions based on deep ethical and
human concerns we can do that we're
capable of it
hi Ellery Biddulph from Global Voices I
I wonder if you could just talk about
there must be political barriers to this
right like I think of Chicago also as
this fairy crony istic place of the sort
of scary power field and so I wonder
what these are all brilliant amazing
ideas to think about but then I also
think of that as a place where people
have very set political agendas that
might not always allow this kind of
stuff to happen the way that you want it
to right that's another version that's a
terrific question it it's what I Perito
said a minute ago how do you keep the
tilt from going the other direction
again civic involvement you know voting
for people who care about these kinds of
issues and and and can hang on to it
politics are everywhere making things
visible actually helps you see
corruption
right you see influence in ways with
data that would be impossible in an
analog world and finding leading
indicators is part of what the data job
does so just as people say oh the
Internet is a terrible problem for the
police because they can't see everything
that's actually not true they're seeing
much more right here too politics are a
problem for setting up the right kinds
of policies in these areas but we can
see what's happening and that's what
gives me optimism and that what gives me
that the sense of responsiveness that
builds trust and in another feedback
loop builds engagement by people in
government when only 20% of people vote
we have an enormous problem because
that's that very thin strand of
relationship that sort of lack of
awareness of the role of government in
your lives get more people involved have
them seeing what government is up to
around them and you've got a richer
ecosystem that doesn't allow for just
coercive power I hike le béret a long
view my question is actually pretty
similar to David's question yeah I
wanted you to elaborate a little bit on
your theory of change I guess yes
because I think you know when I listen
to his question asking about you know
okay
can you basically a lot of these places
you can actually see like physically see
in the physical world you can see
manaphy
stations of the problems themselves and
I know that's definitely true for me I
live in you know neighborhood that has
the worst indicators in Manhattan and I
feel like you know if we had this
additional data it just makes me wonder
like what else we would be able to gain
from that because I think it's pretty
obvious to anyone who visits the
neighborhood and anyone who lives there
that this neighborhood has problems
right terrific question well what you
gain from it is the comparative
visualization so problems here another
area same geographic qualifications but
treated differently or outcomes are
different what you're looking for our
outcomes this is sort of technocratic
way to talk about this where are things
falling apart and being able to see that
another area of the city is getting a
disproportionate share of city resources
getting less attention getting less
funding that helps that build so you're
just not you're not just complaining
about how bad things are in your area
but you're saying and look at these
other places we'd like to be treated
like them and we want to see change that
makes that possible a level playing
field data helps that because people
respond to visualizations of data in
ways that they don't respond to just
pictures of buildings it's a layer of
factual persuasion that isn't available
with anecdotes it really helps it moves
mountains sometimes just showing a
picture of reality using aggregated data
changes people's minds in ways that
telling a story right now using a
picture of a building wouldn't i'm benjy
to the opinion from the knight
foundation so hi two-part question the
first one being who decides what we
respond to yeah right so the thing with
data visualization in big datasets is
there is it's not neutral there's an
editing process yes you decide what we
respond to and there's a historical
basis to responding to the wrong data
right so the most measured thing in
cities is vehicular traffic and so we do
everything to try to expand vehicular
traffic which Urbanists know is just
about the worst thing and historically
redlining was data-driven and algorithms
that the RAND Corporation
in place in early New York in the 1970s
to make fire control more efficient led
to the fires of the Bronx so who decides
what we respond to and and then second
part question which you just said about
the 20% voting particularly in local
elections I think 20% is actually high
how will all of this get more people to
actually get involved mm-hmm let me
start the second part of the question
first I think the suggestion is we have
to test this rigorously the suggestion
is when you have a feeling of agency
that you can effect what happens in your
local neighborhood that your city
government is helping you affect what
happens your neighborhood you become
more engaged it's it's all driven by
agency and trust if you think that
there's this far away city government
that has no effect on your life and
there's no point in your voting you're
not going to vote so we can improve on
the status quo of low voting rates I
think if you increase the sense of
agency autonomy dignity involvement and
impact and you can use data to measure
and depict that in ways that you can't
use pictures in the analog world that's
the theory I'm actually saying what
about this I I think that especially
here in Boston where the mayor managed
to touch so many people both by shaking
hands and by using technology there's a
feeling of enhanced trust which we will
see lead to higher levels of citizen
engagement in voting and in other ways
it's not just voting it's also going to
a neighborhood watch meeting or you know
showing up and picking stuff off the
street all kinds of ways of getting
engaged on the first point it's it keeps
being the same answer for me who decides
that's where policy comes in you know
what if we have a city that understands
that transportation is infrastructure
making possible human lives and not the
thing around which we organize the city
you'll get different desirable outcomes
and then people manage the city towards
those outcomes what's interesting is in
America we went towards the auto
you know 40 years ago and ripped up
infrastructure that had been devoted to
carrying people around now we're putting
it all back in so we've learned and the
impact of design and Urbanists on cities
is growing all the time so policy is
always the answer to who decides and
visualization for me is part of the
answer to who engages hi I'm Rebecca
MacKinnon with the numeration etc hi
Susan
sorry to keep carping on this question
your your antidote to the Big Brother
problem is policy yeah civic engagement
political engagement right so what is
your advice to citizens of Bangkok of
Kiev of Istanbul of Riyadh who are very
much hoping that their city governments
don't implement these systems any time
soon I think they're the answer has to
be the same it comes from activism
protests which gradually changes
structures of government over time it's
stopped
thanks to the surveillance before you
can even engage you find as new America
is helping people find ways to get
around the blocking of the protest other
methods of communicating that make it
possible
look these are extraordinarily difficult
problems and the Internet and the
availability of open Internet access is
actually an instrument of democracy so
that people can find each other and work
towards collective solutions to very
difficult problems I think from an
American standpoint the best thing we
can do is try to make sure that
communication isn't as open as possible
but that's a sovereign country what
they're going to do to decide their own
policies is up to their rules we can
only operate on our own I know that's
not enough of an answer but I think you
push openness as much as possible and
then look for that those increasing
returns to everybody that come from open
Internet access
hi Catherine Ignacio from the center for
civic media I want to ask a question
about the so you showed the critique of
the smart city sure and sort of equating
that with post humanism mmm-hmm and so
in my mind the posthumanist turn has
actually been more about trying to be
inclusive of all of the agencies that
are operating in the city and in a sense
like the caricature of the smart city is
about the total human centeredness of
the city like it's about the domination
of the city by humans so I've seen the
posthuman as turn as being turning us
towards environmental issues turning us
towards these deeper understandings of
things like climate change where we can
understand agencies beyond the scope of
like human timescales and things like
that so I wondering why why is that part
necessary I guess I got you and these
are contested terms they go back and
forth so I was just trying to get
everybody's attention with post humanism
like what's that and why is she talking
about that because the I worry I deeply
worry about a sort of physicist view of
New York City that we measure everything
and therefore we understand the city and
that seems to me to be so alienating and
sort of discouraging like oh forget it I
don't have anything to do with that and
then I look at these other stories of
what can be helped and encouraged and I
tried to push towards that so it's
really a very simple look for me that
actually when it comes to cities humans
really should be at the center and not
treating them as sensors because that's
not a great idea
but using what we know to help their
lives be better better sense of
well-being health is huge here better
resiliency in the city so it's going to
survive the next disaster better
sustainability so people understand what
their energy practices are and how they
might change them so for me the good
parts of that vision outweigh the risks
of the the use of the collection of data
and that's the only story I'm trying to
tell here
so one of the things that I most admire
about really engaged scholars who are
not just writing and trying to make
policy statements but are actually
trying to change the world is their
willingness to think in public and so
I'm really grateful for Susan both for
giving us this provocation but also
really setting the tone for the sort of
conversation that we want to have an
event like this so Susan thank you so
much for for being with us we're it's a
great honor
thank you very much thanks so much